valentine's day just a few days away and
so many of you have love on the brain
yeah but how has the dating scene really
changed since the covet 19 pandemic just
rocked everybody's world
sasha loftus breaks down our new and
slightly more complicated realm of
romance
dating is great but it can also be
daunting once you factor in the stress
and uncertainty of covid19
it can all feel overwhelming we took a
look at how the coronavirus has changed
things for better
or for worse when it's meant to be it's
meant to be whether you're happily
attached
or still searching for that special
someone there's a science behind
any successful romance especially during
the covid19 pandemic
match now really encourages you to do
the video
some like heidi glassman and john
clarice got lucky
i saw a posting that she had made
ironically about
covid and just clicked onto her profile
for some reason i answered his message
while others like laura coronado are
dating in the age of
social distancing now i actually have to
see what is their lifestyle like during
the pandemic
logan yuri is the director of
relationship science at hinch
she says the app has seen a 9 spike in
setup
since march many started with video
dates
people are calling the video date the
new coffee date it's that low pressure
vibe check at the beginning to say
is this something that we should invest
more time into an emotional intimacy
marriage and family therapist donna
wilburn tells me all
apps like tinder bumble and match have
become even more popular over the last
year
bars aren't open social event places
aren't open that people who may not have
used
an app for dating before are really
resorting to using the app
so what about a real commitment wilburn
says
these unparalleled times hit every
couple differently
for a lot of folks it was really a
challenge to find the time for bonding
during the quarantine if you did not
live together and for a lot of folks
it was okay i guess we gotta fast
forward
as for heidi and john they're proof real
love is still
out there you just have to fight a
little harder
to find it it just kind of happened and
i think that's what makes it so special
sasha loftis
8 news now they're cute together donna
wilburn says
if you're nervous it's okay to ask a
potential date if they've been tested or
vaccinated
many apps also have coven safety
settings we have some more tips for you
and full interviews with our some of our
dating experts on our website at
8newsnow.com